kenya is where the reign of queen
elizabeth started but her death has
stirred mixed emotions for a country
that didn't always have the easiest
relationship with the late
in 1952 the then princess elizabeth was
on a royal visit with her new husband
prince philip her trip was cut short
when her father king george vi
unexpectedly died the young princess
became queen whilst on kenyan land a
date that many still fondly remember
in nairobi's rail museum the queen's
royal visits are celebrated
so when she visited kenya in 1993 she
used the royal trade on her way through
nanuki you've got er there elizabeth
regina
why is it important to
preserve this
we are happy because
history was made in kenya during that
time
and we are glad to be part of that
history
but there is another history britain's
colonial rule the british crackdown on
the mao mao uprising killed an estimated
11 000 kenyans and many held the queen
as britain's head of state
responsible kenya was colonized by by
the british and being colonized by the
british people have lost their fathers
they have lost their grandparents here
fighting for independence fighting for
independence from the colonies
so again when this is a colonizer there
are people who that is the feeling they
have
the association with the queen has also
had some positives yes yes their
positives i mean the colonization also
brought positive things but again
there's the negativity bit of the losses
that kenya as a people went through
signs of british colonial history and
the resentment of it are unavoidable in
nairobi
the city's main road was named princess
elizabeth highway when it opened but
since renamed freedom road after
independence
time has healed only so much here king
charles ascended to the throne replacing
the mother this in itself marks a new
beginning i don't think
a great fraction of kenyans will look at
it like that the more critical ones will
remain critical
will still continue to pose their hard
and comfortable questions and will
demand
economic justice
political justice and reparations
britain and kenya share a past and a
future both are members of the
commonwealth
but a new king
won't necessarily be a new beginning
alice to bundle sky news in nairobi